Let's take a look at the GIF editor view
controller in the Objective C project.
We can see that it has three properties.
A GIF image view, a GIF, and then in
the .m file a caption text field.
If we look through
the implementation file.
We see the view controller
lifecycle methods.
We see a bunch of code for
formatting the caption text field.
We see the UI text field
delegate methods, the code for
adjusting the keyboard.
And then a method
called present preview.
Okay, here we are back in the GIF editor
view controller in the SWIFT project and
we'll start by adding those properties.
We already have a property for
the GIF image view.
So we need to add a property for
the caption text field which we
can drag in from storyboard.
And we'll replace this GIF URL
property with a property called GIF.
And we're not really sure when this
GIF property's going to be set.
So we'll make it an optional.
Next you're going to want to
go back to the method,
convert video to GIF, this is in the UI
view controller record extension.
Now, instead of passing the GIF URL
from the convert video to GIF method,
let's go ahead and
initialize an instance of the GIF and
then instead of passing the GIF URL.
We'll just pass the GIF as a parameter
to the display GIF method, and
then we'll go back to our GIF
editor view controller and
set the GIF image view
in view will appear.
So instead of GIF from recording.
It should be gif.gifimage.
Now let's run it and see how it looks.
This will also tell us if everything
is in order with our GIF class.
All right, okay.
Let's launch the camera.
Whoa!
Super we can still see our GIF.
So it looks like everything's
in order with the GIF class.
Hopefully you will be
able to see your GIF too.
And now we'll move on to implement
the UITextField delegate methods.